[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Good afternoon.
And welcome to
our session today.
Can you all hear me OK?
This is going to be a little
different from my normal talks
that actually have
a room, so we're
going to keep it high energy.
So welcome to our talk
this afternoon on See
What's New with Cloud Spanner.
My name is Deepti Srivastava.
I am the Product Manager
for Cloud Spanner,
and I'm very excited to have you
all join me for this session.
So let's move on.
Sorry, the background
is a little distracting,
but let's move.
So before we get into the new
part, let's talk about what
Cloud Spanner is, what
have we been doing so far?
So we launched Cloud Spanner
externally on the GCP platform
last year on Valentine's Day.
And then we quickly went
to general availability.
And in the last 14
or so months, we've
seen some great traction on it.
But before Cloud
Spanner was there,
you had to choose what database
you wanted based on the one
really important
attribute of your database
that you couldn't give up.
So either it was
performance, or scale,
or SQL, or relational semantics,
however you want to put it,
or manageability, right?
Or, or, or, or, or.
And with Cloud
Spanner, basically, you
don't have to make those
compromises anymore.
It is our no compromise
database that
combines the benefits
of both horizontal scale
and performance and the
familiar relational semantics
that you're used to with SQL NC
2011 compliance SQL dialects,
table schemas--
everything you're
used to and like about
relational databases.
So we launched and are currently
available in 13 GCP regions.
We also have multi-region
configurations.
And they give you
four and five nines
of availability, which
means five nines really
means less than five
minutes of downtime a year.
So if you've gone
upstairs and seen
in Moscone West, the fifth
nine-- which is our SRE lounge,
it's worth visiting--
but basically, we
are highly reliable, highly
available database service
offered on Google
Cloud platform.
So why Cloud Spanner?
And how are we releasing
it to the world?
So as I said, Spanner
combines the benefits
of many different
types of systems
so that you don't have to make
those compromises anymore.
But databases have
existed for 30 years.
So we could have started to
add a whole bunch of features
to our database that
we launched last year,
but we wanted to be
deliberate about how
we go about adding features
and functionality to Spanner.
Our philosophy with Cloud
Spanner from the beginning
has been building for
you, for our customers.
We had been using this system
internally for multiple years,
so it's not something that
we picked up and threw over
the fence and said,
hey, have fun with it.
It's not just some cool tech,
but it's actually useful.
And we launched with our basic
functionality that we did.
And then we wanted to
add features as we go,
based on how customers
perceived it and wanted from it.
So we have been deliberate,
and that's something
that I'll talk about as we go.
But you should tell us what
you want us to build next.
So you can find me on
LinkedIn, obviously.
But please tell us
on Stack Overflow,
on those two headings.
And we'd love to know what more
you'd like from the system.
So as I said, we launched
about 14-ish months ago.
And what have we been doing
as we're being deliberate
about adding functionality?
So we added multi-region
configurations.
Again, this is something
that's very popular internally,
but we wanted to make
sure that we provided
this functionality
only it was useful
to our external customers.
And it turns out it was a
very high-demand feature,
so we added it late last year.
We also have admin and
data access logging.
We have Stackdriver
integrations and metrics
and more metrics coming.
We keep adding metrics
based on what you all
are looking for,
rather than, oh, here's
a whole bunch of metrics,
and now figure out
how to tune your
system based on it.
We have a very cool
feature, again,
that was internally
used, but also it
looks like it's very
useful externally,
which is commit timestamps, that
we launched earlier this year.
And that allows you to
basically log transactionally
when a transaction committed.
So as part of a
transaction to a row,
you can actually
write the timestamp
which is that
transaction committed,
which allows you to
build many, many things,
like change logs, triggers,
change [INAUDIBLE] capture,
et cetera, on top of it.
We also have open
census integration
for more debugging, again,
and then, of course,
compliance certification.
And the list goes on, but
these are some of the things
that, again, we're
asked for, and we've
tried to deliver deliberately.
So before we move
on, Cloud Spanner
has seen tremendous
adoption across all industry
and across all verticals.
And I'm so excited to have one
of our very cool customers here
today from Belgium to tell
us more about their use case.
Mark is from
nexuzhealth, and he's
going to tell us
a little bit more
about how they're using Spanner.
So Mark?
MARK VANAUTGAERDEN: Hi.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Take it away.
MARK VANAUTGAERDEN: Thank you.
So hello.
So my name is Mark,
Mark Vanautgaerden.
I'm from nexuzhealth,
and I'll just
give you a little overview of
what we are and what we do.
So probably you don't know us--
Belgium, small country
somewhere in Europe.
We played fairly well
in the Cup, they say.
And in Belgium, there is a
large University Hospital.
It's called UZ Leuven.
It's quite a large university
and training hospital.
It's about 2,000 beds and
about 9,000 medical staff.
And there is all centralized IT.
So we do everything centralized,
so nothing is decentralized.
And we do it with about
180 hats, currently.
Over the last 25
years, we've been
building our own internal
electronic medical records
system.
And that we call internally
the clinical work station.
And it's what was important
from the very beginning
that it's the one stop
for everything you
do with the patient data.
So not just for
physicians, but also
for the nursing, for the
administrative people,
et cetera, everybody inside.
It's patient-centric, and it's
very, very workflow oriented.
So it has a big burden on
workflow also on the database.
And so all of it for
those who are familiar,
gives lots of
functionality, not just
the classical medical report,
but lots of older thing,
like planning, and order
entry, and drugs prescription,
and administration,
et cetera, et cetera--
so a complete patient
management system.
So that was quite successful
over the last 25 years.
And we rolled it
out gradually in
that large academic hospital.
It was so successful that
a lot of other hospitals
in the region said, whoa, why
can't we have that system?
Why don't you sell it to us?
And we said, well, we
don't sell it, yet.
At that moment, that
was 10 years ago.
So we said, why don't
you just join us.
And we're not going to do to
sell it and give you the CD
and install it with you, just
join us in the same database
and act like you're
working in our hospital,
but just on another side.
So at that time, it was just by
accident that we said, well, go
and [INAUDIBLE]
at one big system.
But gradually, it evolved in
a very important thing, namely
that we built one
central medical file
across the complete
region of Flanders
with all patient data
in there, centrally,
without having the
difficulty of connecting
between all different systems.
So it means that it's
a very big offering.
So we optimize across hospitals,
workflows, and data flow.
So whenever you
enter data here, it's
automatically at the other side.
And there's no
data going across.
It's a big advantage
in Flanders.
So currently, there's about 30
hospitals connected to that.
21 are currently
in full production.
The other ones are
still connected to it.
So as I said, it's one
big shared medical record.
That currently, about 13,000
beds managed in that system.
And that are 30,000 named
users in the system.
And every three minutes, there
are about 6,000 users active
in the database.
So that is the current set up.
And well, we grow fast
over the last year.
For those who are a bit
familiar with the geography,
this is Belgium, northern part.
So some of you will recognize in
the center, there is Brussels.
Some of you have heard of that.
And also, there is something
like Antwerp Ghent, and Bruges.
You're familiar with that.
So over the last 10
years, all of a sudden,
we were across Flanders,
and across Flanders
that when you live at
the sea, at the coast,
and you have a very big
problem, medical problem,
you are sent to that
big central hospital
somewhere around
Brussels in Leuven.
And they automatically have
all your medical data there.
And it's a big plus.
And afterwards,
you go back home,
and all data is transferred
automagically again,
and it's a big plus.
But what does it mean?
We currently have about 50%
of the Belgium patients beds
and hospitals in that system.
Also, it's all in
one big database.
Well, wow.
And it does about 1 million
plus transactions a day.
So that is that setup.
The current architecture
is quite, quite classical.
So we do it all ourselves.
It's basically a
client-server architecture.
So with a very big,
one central instance
database in the middle
that is core to everything,
and then connected, of
course, to the clients--
either the laptops, or there
is mobile applications,
or there is e-health
connections, et cetera,
et cetera.
But sole driven by
that one, big database.
As you can imagine,
we grow a bit fast.
And it wasn't envisioned
to be that big.
So there is a big risk on that.
And what do we need?
We said, OK, let's look
for a new solution that
is more future-proof and that
we can grow even further.
But we have a lot of
constraints, currently.
And as you can see, size
is an important stuff.
So of course, we are
about 14 terabytes
of online data in there.
We do not do any
archiving in there.
Availability, of
course, for a hospital--
very, very important.
You could live with the
computer is out for a minute
during a very important surgery.
But 10 minutes?
Whoa, that will be a problem.
So you will not have that.
Scalability in our environment
is really important
because those 30 hospitals
will not be the end of it.
We will only grow over that.
And of course, you can imagine
security in a hospital,
this is a prime thing.
We have very complex
transactions.
And just to give you an
idea, into that system,
we have about 7,000 tables
with about 5,000 triggers
that have 300,000
lines of SQL code,
and managing all that
complexity of transactions.
Another big thing
that we have is we
do weekly releases, consistently
over the last 25 years.
And we want to keep
that because it's
very important for all
things of new ideas
pop up in the health care.
Also, in health care,
deletionless data
is very important.
Every data that goes in
never gets deleted, updated,
or anything.
It just needs to remain there.
We need to know at
every moment in time
what the status of
the patient was,
and we need to go back for that.
And we have no
maintenance, we know.
As I just said, you can be down
for one, two, to three minutes.
But going down for
longer than that
is not an option in a hospital.
Of course, this is a
big challenge for us.
And so we want that burden
somebody else's problem,
and not our problem anymore.
So we looked around,
and what can we do?
And just to give you an
idea of what we currently
do with our system-- so we
have that one big database,
as I said.
But of course, technically,
it's all a set up
of three logical servers
being logically replicated
to each other, just to make sure
that one is the primary server.
But whenever
something goes wrong,
you can quickly switch
to another server.
And then the user
will not see that.
But also, it's structurally
done for doing maintenance,
because, as I say, we don't
have a maintenance window.
But that says that
the user doesn't want
to see a maintenance window.
But of course you,
as a DB admin,
you need to do maintenance.
So how do you do that?
We keep those three
servers up and running.
So one is the primary, and the
two other are hot standbys.
But not only that, we
also have warm standbys
because those hot standbys,
they are hot standbys.
It means that whenever
you do something
logically wrong on
the primary server,
it automatically gets replicated
within seconds, or at most
a minute, to the other servers.
And then the accident is gone,
and you do not have the data.
So therefore, we currently have
that setup of warm standbys
where you lag about
an hour, or a day,
and to make sure
that you can just
retrieve in case of a
logical error the data there.
And then apart from
that, of course,
you have all the other
copies for doing development,
for doing testing, for
doing training, et cetera,
read-only for clinical
trials, and so on and so on.
So we now envision
a new application.
And the application is not
just for the hospitals,
but we're immediately going to
attract also the first line.
So we're also going to go to
the primary care, so the family
doctors, GPs, home nursing,
et cetera, et cetera,
into that system, so all
your data is automatically
connected.
We call it the MOAPR.
It's a very, very
unsexy name, I know,
but its an acronym for
something that stuck inside.
And we say its the Mother
Of All Patient Records.
So that's what we're
trying to build.
And therefore, we needed a
big, stable, and good solution
for the back end.
So what is our
current architecture
that we're building?
In the front end, we have
a Angular environment.
Talks in the middle tier
to a GO middle tier.
It's all nicely
connected with the GRPC.
And in the Google
Cloud Platform,
it's always very nice to have
that reiterations over and over
again from your APIs,
as we are currently
developing continuously.
And in the back, it's driven
by Cloud Spanner, of course.
Apart from that, we
also have pops up
to go to the Google BigQuery.
And there, we do
currently our requirement
of the deletionless data
so that we can always
track all versions of the
data that were ever there.
Of course, our DBAs, as typical
DBAs of an on-prem environment
are, they're very scary
about the cloud solution.
They say, well, will
this really work?
So they did a lot of
extensive performance testing,
and so on, and so on, to make
sure that, yes, this will work.
And so they just give
me some overviews
of testing that they did.
And they basically
said, whatever
we tried with Cloud Spanner,
it just scales linearly.
So no worries.
This will work for us.
So we're very happy to have
been working with the team.
And now, it's back
to you, Deepti.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Thank you.
MARK VANAUTGAERDEN: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
You can't get better
than Mother Of All patient.
Records, right?
So thank you, Mark.
He'll be here later
on for questions,
if you have any, more details.
And we also are joined
by Bart from Belgium.
So we can get into that
in the Q&A section.
But now, let's actually
move on to why you all
are here, which is to learn
more about what's new.
So again, going back to our
product philosophy of building
what you all and our customers
have been asking for,
the first question I get asked,
and the second, and the tenth
is, what about
disaster recovery?
So I'm very happy to talk
about our launch last week
of our import/export
functionality.
And it allows you to do a bunch
of different use cases, not
just disaster recovery.
But the highlights here are that
it's a UI functionality that's
push-button.
So you can take a consistent
dump of your Spanner database
and put it, by default,
in a GCS bucket,
using our Apache Beam-based
Dataflow connectors.
And it's stored, by
default, in our Apache Avro
format, which is, again
another open source format.
And again, with the
push of a button,
you can import the data
back into Cloud Spanner.
So what this does is allows
you to take your own backups,
at your convenience, and store
them in a different medium
to get even better
separation of concerns here.
It also enables a couple
of other interesting use
cases, which is you
can actually take
this dump, this export of
your production Cloud Spanner
database, and use it for
dev test environments.
So you can load it into
a different environment
for dev and testing.
You can do database
configuration moves.
What I mean by that is you can
export a Cloud Spanner data out
and put it in a
different configuration.
Because ultimately,
you can import it
into any Cloud Spanner
configuration that you want.
So it allows you to go from
one configuration to another.
It also allows you to do
things, like export it out,
and then allow BigQuery to
do analytics on your database
as well.
So it makes it a
little bit easier.
So you don't have to
ETL it, necessarily.
You can just dump
it out, and then
have BigQuery just point it to
a GCS bucket of your choice.
And it'll put the
data into BigQuery.
And then-- my
slides are ghosting.
[LAUGHS] So I don't know
what's going on with that.
But just imagine that we
have that slide on use cases.
And the last use case that
I'm talking about is BigQuery.
So why just talk about
it when we can actually
see it in action?
So please welcome
Steve on stage,
who's one of the lead engineers
on Spanner, who is here to help
me drive this demo with you.
I'm going to stand
way over here.
So if you're not
familiar with Spanner,
this is our cloud console.
I'm very proud of it.
It's very clean.
And we are actually in a
Cloud Spanner instance,
which is a collection
of resources and also
a configuration unit.
And this one is called
Import/Export Demo Instance.
Not very creative,
but informative.
And we're looking at a YCSB
database for this demo.
So it's a very simple database.
It has one table
with multiple keys.
And it is two terabytes.
In this case, we've loaded
two terabytes of data.
And we're going to try
and export and import
this database.
So now you can see, if you're
familiar with the console,
we have two new
buttons at the top.
One is an Import button,
and the other one's Export.
So let's first export
this existing database.
And at the click of a button,
[CHUCKLES] some magic happens.
I think there's a Harry
Potter in the venue somewhere.
So there's a button
that got clicked.
And it brought up a screen
where you can simply
specify which GCS bucket you
want to put your data in.
And then you can--
Steve is selecting that.
Again, we're not
imaginative, but informative.
That's what database people are.
And then we choose
the database we want.
In this case, we want
the YCSB database.
And then we also want to choose
the compute region for running
the Dataflow compute jobs.
So remember, we're using
our platform, Dataflow,
for doing this export, right?
And so you have to specify
where to run the Dataflow
jobs in order to
export this data out.
And then you hit Export.
And voila, you have a two
terabyte database that's
being exported right now.
So as you can see here,
it brings you back
to this Database Details page
where you can see the banner.
So the point is, no
matter who you are,
and if you navigate away from
this page and come back to it,
you will know that there is
an export happening right now,
currently.
And so this is helpful if you
have a team of people looking
at the instance in
the database, and you
want to know that something
is happening right now.
So you can actually
go view the database
job details from
this banner itself,
but we actually have a
handy-dandy Import/Export tab.
So that will maintain a
history of all the things, all
the imports and exports, that
you've done for this database.
And so you can see there's
one that's running right now.
Let's actually look at,
in the interest of time--
and hopefully, no
more magic happens--
let's look at an
existing Dataflow
job that ran previously.
And the idea here is that
we make it easy for you
to debug your Dataflow jobs.
So we just take you to the
page with the Dataflow details.
And you can see how the
Dataflow draw ran, what it did.
And you can also see on
the side panel info pane
how long it took, what type of
work or auto-scaling happened,
et cetera.
So this is helpful in debugging
your previous Dataflow jobs
and maybe optimizing them as
your data size grows, or things
like that.
So now let's go back
to our instance again.
While this is running, let's
actually do an import back
into Cloud Spanner as well.
So again, Steve is showing you
how quickly he can go and do
an import where you can choose
a database of your choice
where you want to import it.
Again, you have to specify
the GCS bucket to import from.
And again, you have to
choose a Dataflow region
to run those Dataflow jobs,
now to import data back
into Cloud Spanner, right?
And there's no magic here.
Please, no magic.
But now we're importing
this two terabyte database.
Again, you can see
the job flow details
on our handy-dandy
Import/Export tab.
And again, there's
a couple that fails.
You know, we're
being honest here.
It's a live demo.
And you can see
that, again, there's
this import happening for
this particular database.
So that gives you
a whirlwind tour--
if we can switch back
to the slides, maybe.
Hm.
Doot, doo, doot, doo, doo.
So that gave you
a whirlwind tour
of the Import/Export
functionality,
which we released last week.
The next question out, maybe the
11th, is more about DML, right?
So this is the ability to
do SQL queries in Spanner.
So Spanner allows you to do
INSERT, UPDATE, and DELETE,
obviously, but
through the RPC API.
And so far, you
couldn't do it in SQL.
But I am very happy
to say that we're
working on this functionality,
so that you could
do SQL queries inside Scanner.
So what this means
is that you can now
use your existing and
standard traditional tooling
for databases, including JDBC
drivers and other drivers
and ORMs.
And Spanner's
looking and feeling
and smelling a lot more like
your traditional databases.
So with this functionality,
you can do INSERT, UPDATE,
and DELETE in SQL.
You can do complex queries.
We will have this functionality,
like with all Spanner
functionality almost, we'll
it in the UI, CLI, and API.
And when we release
DML, we will also
support it in the JDBC
driver that we already have.
So again, this is not about any
timeline or anything like that,
I just wanted to show you that
what we're working on and to--
again, why talk about it when
you can see it in action?
So Steve is going to help
me again with this demo,
if we can switch the screens.
Thank you.
So I'm going to
stand way over here.
This time, again, we're
back to the query console.
And we are looking at
a different database.
So hang on.
So we're looking at a different
database this time, which
is a ticket info database.
So this is a little bit more
interesting than the YCSB one.
As you can see on
the side, the schema
shows that we have Event table,
Account table, Ticket table,
et cetera.
So it's a fairly
standard database.
And Event table here has
two indices, as well.
So let's run a query to
see what events we have.
So in the query console,
you can run SQL queries.
And you can see the
results right here.
And as you can
see, the main thing
here is that there isn't
any multi-event IDs set.
So if we go to the
explanation, actually, you
can see that it's using
an event by date index.
So it's doing the
right thing to be
running the query efficiently.
And if we go back,
now, let's do something
interesting with
this table, which
is to change the multi-event
ID for all events that started
yesterday to Cloud Next, because
Cloud Next started yesterday.
So-- ooh, DML query completed.
And again, if you look
at the query plan,
now we support DML
operations in the query
we plan to apply mutation.
Sorry, I hope you can see this.
And just to make sure that
we're not fooling you,
let's actually see
the Event table again.
And hopefully, we'll
see a multi-event ID
being updated for
all events that
are starting as of yesterday.
Look.
It got updated.
Woo-hoo!
So DML actually works.
And now, let's do something a
little bit more interesting,
because I have a bunch of
customers who say, well,
but will you be able
to do conditionals,
and WHERE clauses,
and IF clauses,
and all that sort of stuff?
In your distributed database
that can, by the way,
scale to petabyte-scale
databases.
So here, we have
the Attendees table.
So basically, we have a
list of attendees here.
And what we want to do
is mark all the attendees
that are coming to my
session today VIPs,
because we like you all.
So here, we can see that
Alice and Carol are attending
the Spanish session,
so we're going
to mark them as VIPs for
the rest of the event.
Now, disclaimer.
This doesn't actually hook into
the actual events for today.
So if you are Alice
and Carol, you
won't be a VIP, unless
you already are.
But the idea here
is that we should
be able to update this
with the conditional
and add the VIP tag.
So let's actually look at the
query again and see if we can--
[LAUGHS] It doesn't matter.
Live demo, people.
So basically, we should update
this Attendees table with--
[LAUGHS] with VIP status
for Alice and Carol.
Perfect.
It works.
And we demonstrated that
we are canned, right?
So that gives you a whirlwind
tour of our DML functionality
that we're working on.
It should, as I said,
give you a look and feel
of Spanner, similar
to other databases
and should make it easier
for you to both migrate
and then use it with
your existing tooling.
So moving on, another thing
that is frequently asked
is performance tuning.
So this is common
for all databases.
Everybody wants more--
[LAUGHS] I can
high-five you as well.
Everybody wants more
insight into their database,
because they know
they can do better
than what the database
is doing automatically,
no matter what we think about
our heuristic algorithms.
So we're working on another
exciting new feature
that I'm going to have Anna
step up here and help me demo.
Anna is one of the lead
engineers for this feature.
It's called Query Statistics.
Again, this is something
that's coming soon.
We're planning to release
it later this year.
But I'm very excited about
it because it gives you
introspection into your
worst performing queries.
And there are multiple
additional dimensions
along which we report stats.
So you can see what's
going on with your queries.
And of course, we'll have this
available in our API and our UI
in multiple granularity buckets.
So let's see it in action
if you could switch, please.
So we're back to our UI console.
Now, we're just doing
it in the UI console
because it's easier
to see and understand.
But of course, we'll have it
programmatically, as well.
So this is the same
ticket info schema
that we saw earlier with the
account, and event, and venue,
and whatnot.
But this time, we have an
exciting new tab called,
Query Statistics.
So what you can see when you
get into the Query Statistic tab
is all of the queries that
ran in the last minute,
in this case, that are
hogging the most CPU.
So they're the most
resource-intensive,
and we're looking at
sorting them per CPU.
And where Anna's cursor
is is basically we
have multiple buckets in
which you can see that.
So you can not only see what
happened in the last minute,
but the last hour, the
last 24 hours, et cetera.
But we're going to
stick to the last minute
and see our top query.
So if you click
on it, we actually
give you a lot more information
on the side in our Info panel.
And as you can see, the
query took 261 CPU seconds.
It'll give you a lot
more information,
like latency, rows
scanned, and rows sent.
Now, in this case,
they're both the same,
which means that the query
was not doing any aggregations
or filtering.
And if you look at
the handy-dandy query
text on the top, you
can see that, indeed, it
was not doing any
aggregations and filtering.
But it is a parameterized query.
And this is a good time
to talk about using
parameterized queries,
because they actually
make your queries
perform more efficiently,
because the query engine
can store the query plan
and not have to rebuild it
every time you run the query.
It also gives us
better statistics
for things like query stats.
And even if you invoke
the query multiple times,
it will store the
information for you
because it's using
the same plan.
So in this case, the query was
run in the last minute 150,000
times, almost.
And all of that is
aggregated and put together
in this Query Statistics.
So let's look at a
more interesting query.
So let's look at all the
venues by seating capacity.
And in this case, you can see
that the total CPU here taken
was 24 seconds,
but the average CPU
is much, much less than that.
And what that means
is the Spanner, which
is meant to distribute, is meant
to be parallelizing queries,
is actually doing that, and
so giving you the response
in a much shorter time.
Even though the execution
count is much smaller,
so it's just another query
in your top 10 queries.
So what if you wanted
to debug this query
and see what it
did in real time?
So you can click on this button
to open into our Query Console.
Very cool, I think.
We are database geeks,
so what we think is cool
is not necessarily
cool for everybody.
But as you can see here,
the query ran, in this case.
And it gave us a list of all the
venues with seating capacity.
And if you wanted
to debug it, you
would want to look at the
query explanation as well,
to see what it's doing, right?
And this is the explain
plan for this particular run
of the query, of course.
And you can see it's doing all
the things you expect it to.
It's doing a hash and
then an aggregation
to return the results to
you in descending order.
Cool.
So hopefully, that was a
fun demo for you all of what
we're working on.
Thank you, Anna and Steve, for
running those demos for us.
And if we can
switch back, great.
So those are some very
exciting features-- one
of the two exciting features
that we're working on
that I wanted to show to you
all to make sure you understand
that we are listening to you
and we are working on things.
And we plan to
release both of these
in the next couple of months.
So before we end, I wanted to
also address a couple of points
that I've heard over the past
year that we've been around
and talk about some of the
myths that I see happening.
So I wanted to do a little
bit of myth busting.
So is Cloud Spanner really the
right database for your app?
I hear this a lot.
You know, Cloud Spanner is meant
only for very large workloads.
And the fact is that
Spanner is actually
built so that you
can start with it
and never have to re-platform.
The idea is fire and forget.
You start with it,
and then you never
have to think about
sharding or which
scale, versus performance,
versus name your thing
that you care about,
because it can just
grow with your application.
So you want to focus on
getting the next billion users.
We're right there with you.
We can help you grow
as you grow, right?
In fact, what we've
seen is that--
and this is a known statistic--
like most average enterprise
database sizes are
hundreds of gigabytes
and up to a terabyte or two.
And average Cloud
Spanner database sizes
are right smack in the
middle of that, right?
We have one database that is
35 terabytes, and it's growing.
Great.
But the idea is that you can use
Spanner for the entire spectrum
because you're getting
the benefit of a managed
database that is scalable,
that is parallelizable,
that is secure,
all in one package.
We have regional
configurations and
multi-region configurations.
Whichever one you use is great.
Multi-region configurations
offer high availability,
if that's what you want.
And they can lower
latency, so you can use it
as a content distribution system
for your transactional data,
if that's what you want.
But that has nothing
to do with size.
It's to do with
your requirements
and making the right choice
for your requirements.
And also, as I said, with the
Import/Export functionality,
for example, if you started
out with a regional instance,
and you thought, oh, I actually
need to be multi-region
because, you know,
I'm now popular
everywhere in the world.
And I really want to
grow my health care
business all over the world.
Then you can just
take a snapshot,
move into a multi-region
configuration.
So Cloud Spanner is being
used for typical enterprise
and other database
workloads, and we can expect
for it to continue to do that.
The other thing I
hear quite often
is Cloud Spanner is expensive.
And when you look at
total cost of ownership,
actually, in most
cases, Cloud Scanner
actually gives you great
value for your money
because it's fully managed.
You don't have to have teams
of people carrying pagers--
or if you're a startup
and you have one person,
that person carrying
pagers all the time.
There's no planned downtime.
There's no patches or upgrades
to be added, or whatever.
It's high availability.
It's replicated.
And it has security and
compliance built-in.
We don't nickel and dime
you and say, you get this.
But if you want this,
you have to pay me
so much more, and then so much
more, and so much more, right?
We want to be open
and transparent
and give you the best
platform for your applications
and not have to have
you worry about what
is my monthly bill
going to look like.
And of course, storage
auto-scales, so you never
have to provision storage.
And more importantly,
you don't have
to bring your entire database
down to provision the storage,
right?
And you can scale up and
down the compute as you need,
as you want to go.
So you can actually
increase compute on-demand,
if you have expected
high load because it's
Black Friday, or whichever,
Mother's Day, or whatever.
And you can tune
it down when you
need for a lower number
of nodes if you need that.
So you have elastic
compute, and you
have auto-scaling storage
in a fully managed,
secure, compliant database.
And of course, Brad mentioned
this earlier in the keynote
today, but we are industry
leading in our SLAs.
So we have four nines of
SLA for regional, five
nines of SLA for multi-region.
And as I said, you
future-proof your apps,
because you start with
Spanner, and you don't
have to re-platform, ever.
So that was all I had.
[MUSIC PLAYING]